The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so that's
a good start to Battlecode
Lecture 2.
Welcome.
Today, we'll be talking about
how to write your first player
and then at 6:00 PM we're going
to be having some Indian food.
I'm pretty excited.
And it looks like there will
be enough Indian food for all
of you.
I correctly estimated how many
of you would show up today.
Isn't that a curious
aspect of statistics,
that you cannot tell what one
person is going to do tomorrow,
but you can tell, very
accurately, what everyone,
in aggregate, is
going to do tomorrow?
Quite interesting.
I believe in 2006, the number
of automobile accident deaths
was correctly estimated
to the last man,
or something absolutely
crazy like that.
Because it's a number like
40,000 and it was unbelievable.
So with that heartwarming opener
about automobile homicide,
I'm going to play
some slightly less--
some slightly more
calming images.
So you'll see here
on the screen is
the evolution of a
very simple rule.
This rule is
something like sum up
the number of nearest neighbors
and if that number is even then
the square will be
white in the next turn,
and if the number is odd then
the square will be black.
It's something like
that, in essence.
And it ends up making this
repeating pattern that
is quite mesmerizing to see
and is an excellent example
of emergent complexity.
So, what we'll be
doing today is we're
going to write code
that's pretty darn simple.
A rule like mod two =
zero, something like that.
And what we're going to
get is some really awesome
looking behavior that comes
out of that very simple rule.
So there you go, that's
my tie-in for that.
Administration
stuff, so here I've
brought up the
Battlecode website.
You should all be set up with
Eclipse right now, already.
If you haven't then
you're falling behind,
but then again, at
the same time you've
saved yourself some
effort because we've just
put out another release.
So, what you want to do
is download the installer
and install it to
the same directory
where you currently
have Battlecode.
And that should
update everything
without deleting the
progress that you've
made on your player.
So there's that.
There's also some
exciting things
I'm supposed to be announcing.
That we'll be giving away prizes
for things other than winning.
So, if you're going
to see my amazing code
and you're going to
go, man, I didn't
think I could do that well.
Although, I find
it much more likely
that you could watch what I'm
going to do and then go, pfft,
I could have done
that in my sleep,
I can't believe this guy.
But yeah, we'll be
giving away prizes
for doing things other
than winning this year.
And those things I'll be
announcing throughout the year
so you can keep them in the
back of your mind and be like,
oh I have code that does that I
should think about doing this.
There will be beating
the reference player
with the fewest total bytecodes,
beating the reference player
in the shortest possible time.
By the way, we haven't
released the reference player.
We will be releasing one within
the next couple of weeks.
And, I don't know
if I've said it yet,
but to get credit
for the course you
have to beat the reference
player that we'll
provide on a map
set that we provide.
So it'll be called
reference player
and there will be more
information about that later.
You're also able to get credit
by writing a short report
on how your code
works if you weren't
able to beat the
reference player.
So don't fret too much.
So, those two ways are
ways of winning money.
You can also have the most
interesting use of our source
code, like if you want to
make it so that Nyan Cats are
part of Battlecode, or
some other silly thing,
that might get you something.
And there's also most
impressive non-winning strategy,
which may very well be the
thing that we see today.
All right, so here I'm
going to go to Eclipse,
this is our supported
development environment,
and I'm going to start
setting up a new player.
So, I've got all these extra
Battlecode installs because
of the development
nonsense that went on.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to just start
from scratch and I'm
going to make sure
that I talk about the functions
that I'm using in ways that
are useful to both beginners
and intermediate people.
So, beginners have to
like hurry to catch up
and intermediate people are more
hearing about the Battlecode
API and hearing about how things
are put together, specifically,
about Battlecode that
they wouldn't already
know from their job
experience, for example.
So, let's start this way.
I'm going to make
a new team that I
can fight against my
other teams that are here.
Because I want to
keep trying this.
A big thing about
programming is making
it iteritable-- Iterable?
Iterable.
Interval implements runnable,
anyway these kinds of things.
And so, you'll want to have
a bunch of different robots
that can play
against one another.
And so, you can be
like, all right,
I'm going to right-click
this team's folder
and I'm going to go
to Create Package
and I'm going to
call it-- What's
a good name for this awesome
robot that we're going to make?
Yeah, Awesome Robot.
OK.
Play Awesome Robot player, all
right, I guess that's decent.
Yeah.
And then, in this
one, I go New File,
and I call it robotplayer.java.
It has to be called that because
that's the thing that our game
engine is looking for.
So then, at the very
top, we're going
to write down package
Awesome Robot player,
and then we're going
to put a semi-colon.
Yeah, because you've
got to do that.
Then we'll import
everything in Battlecode.
So, we can use the Battlecode,
the Battlecode API which
is here in
battlecode.common.star.
So that'll give us everything
that's in the Java Docs.
So, what I'll want to do
is have open the Java Docs,
maybe in one window
or on the side,
and have open this
in another window
so that I can bounce
back between them.
I'm not going to do
that at the moment
because that would make
things even harder to see.
So, what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to increase the
text size because I
know some of you
at the back are not
going to be able to see
100% of what I'm doing.
If you want to follow along
on your laptops, go ahead.
I believe we'll be able to
post this code after lecture,
so don't worry too
much about making sure
that you can type
as slowly as I can.
Awesome.
Is that too big?
It might be.
Here we're going to-- we're
just going to run straight in.
So, public class RobotPlayer.
You've got to write that.
So now, so you've written that.
The Java IDE, you notice,
will put these brackets
in for us real nice.
And you need a run method,
public static void run.
And that's going to take the
argument, RobotController,
and then you can name
it whatever you want.
I generally call it myRC.
So, this RobotController object
is the thing that is a robot.
So, when you run this code
every robot has is its own myRC.
And so, the methods of myRC,
which you'll see later,
will apply to that
particular robot.
You'll see some examples.
So, what I like to do
is I like to make--
I like to define the variable
for this RobotController
object.
I like to define
a variable so it
can be used throughout this
class, throughout this package.
So I'm going to type private
static RobotController RC.
And RC is going to be the
thing that I define to myRC.
I'm just going to say, there
you are, now you've got it
and I can use all of the
methods in RobotController
by typing rc.
and then, bingo,
right there, you
see Eclipse is telling me
all of the methods that
are in the Battlecode.common
directory that
are all these methods
that you can use.
So, right here,
it's like this is
a really convenient
way of doing things.
And so, you're going to see
that throughout today's lecture.
So, what I want to do
is I want to make sure
that I've got everything
organized in a way
that I can use it.
Because I'm sure everybody
here has written code
in some language or other that
just goes on and on and on
and it's absolutely massive.
And so, every time you
want to make a change down
here, and up, and down here,
you just get a headache
and you have to fall over
and it's not very good.
Because you could be at
elevation and falling over
at elevation is highly damaging.
So, what we want is
this method will run,
but if we only run it like
this let's see what happens.
Can any of you
guess what's going
to happen if we run
Awesome Robot player?
AUDIENCE: It's going to die.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
It's going to die.
Can you tell me why
it's going to die?
AUDIENCE: Because run will
reach the end of the method.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right, because run will
reach the end of a method.
So, both of the teams explode.
I'm kind of curious which
team won that match.
Let's see here.
It says they both died.
Ah, Team A won.
Good thing to know, Team A
will win if both teams die.
So, let's make a while true.
Yeah, yeah, all right,
the game's unbalanced.
I recognize that.
We'll patch it in, I don't know,
in two seconds or ten minutes,
or whatever.
We're up to-- did I mention
that we're up to 1.1.0.
So, definitely go install that.
1.1.1, that's so fast.
Our development
cycle is amazing.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So, while true
will just keep looping and so
let's try this,
let's do while true.
What's going to happen?
Can anybody tell me what's going
to happen when I do while true?
Something that's undesirable.
AUDIENCE: It's going to stall?
PROFESSOR: These guys are
going to use 10,000 bytecodes
because they just keep looping,
while true, while true,
while true, while true.
And I guess, this
one comparison,
this going to the end of the
loop and coming to the top,
I guess, costs some
non-zero amount.
So, they end up reaching their
bytecode limit, that's no good.
So if we do RC.yield
that ends the turn.
So, whatever happens here
above rc.yield will happen
and then it will go
to the next round.
So now the bytecode usage
for each robot, you'll see--
and right now all we've got
are these headquarters robots--
the bytecodes used is three.
I'll just have to read
it out because it's
so small you can't see.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's three so
that's fantastic.
That's the minimum
that you can get.
All right, so now we're
going to put real stuff in.
We want the headquarters
to behave differently
from the robots.
For example, because the
headquarters can never move,
it can't walk around.
So let's use if rc.
Now, what we want is we want to
figure out what type of robot
it is, so let's look at
the different options here.
Oh look, there is an rc.getType.
Yeah.
All right, so now
we can just say
if that = RobotType.SOLDIER.
That's not what I wanted.
Soldie-- Yeah, if
it's a soldier then
we can put soldier code
here and, otherwise, we
can put headquarters code here.
So, let's make a very
simple, a very simple thing.
Let's say we want to
just kill the enemy.
Kill them.
Kill them dead.
So, let's have, let's
have us do this.
We will define a new variable,
right here now, in this space.
Direction dir =
rc.getLocation.directionTo.
And now, we'll just-- we want
to go straight to the enemy.
We want to make, we want to
find the direction to the enemy
and then we want to
go that direction.
So it's telling me
there's an error
because the directionTo
needs a direction to what.
So let's give it a location.
We're going to give
it the location
rc.senseEnemyHQLocation.
So, there you go.
Now we've already
got the direction.
I'm going to put a semicolon
at the end of the line.
And now, I can see I'm going
to try to go that direction.
To move in a direction
you've got to be active.
Because there are
certain things you
can do, like laying
mines and defusing them,
that make you inactive.
So, I'm going to
check if I'm active.
If rc.
is active which returns a
Boolean true if I'm active.
Well then, let's go
ahead and try to move.
And we'll see what
happens when we
try this, rc.move
in direction dir.
And so, now we're
just going to see,
we're going to see what happens.
Oh, what's this?
It's telling me that an
unhandled exception is here.
Move can throw exceptions.
And so what we do is we put
in add throws declaration.
So then, up here
RobotController is
going to throw an error if
this thing has a problem.
And this is a way
you can use-- this
is Java's built-in
form of debugging.
And you're going to find it very
useful because when you have
a problem, it'll tell
you what the problem is.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Hm, well, the problem is
we don't have any soldiers,
we can't produce any
units, so there's
nobody who can run this code.
So, let's go ahead and add in
some unit spawning abilities
right over here.
So I'm going to go to
example folks player,
open up
robotplayer.Java, and I'm
going to copy this part
which is for if the robot is
a headquarters.
And I'm just going to go ahead
and paste it right in there.
And now, all of a sudden,
I'm spawning units
at random directions around
myself as the headquarters.
So now, we should have units
in our Awesome Robot player
and they start to
run at one another.
Oh, but something
strange is happening,
when they run into one
another it seems like they
are immediately colliding
and exploding, boom.
That one exploded, and then that
one exploded, and that one did.
That's weird looking, isn't it?
It almost looks like this
guy is changing color,
but no, they're running into
each other and exploding.
And the problem, it's not just
that they're going too fast,
because that isn't
the thing, it's
that there's a game
action exception.
And you can see here that
there's tons of exceptions.
And they all showed up here.
And I can be like, OK, I don't
understand anything at all,
I can't read any of this
language, oh, but look,
it says robotplayer.Java:15.
I can just click
there and it shows
me what's throwing
the exception.
Oh, it's this line.
Oh, I see, I see, it's
having trouble moving there
because, maybe, there's
something in the way.
So let's also stipulate that rc.
move in the direction.
This is another
method that's provided
to you that lets you check
whether the direction is
movable.
So now, when we run
the code, they're
going to just go
to the middle, kiss
and kill each other
nice and slow.
Just like that.
Wow, that's beautiful.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And I
think that's just
going to happen all day long
until the end of, see when you
get past a certain number
of rounds, the headquarters
begin to take end
of round damage.
So you can see, the headquarters
are just going to die.
And that happens.
And they both die at once.
And I believe player
A will have won.
Oh no, player B won.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Now, let me
tell you, that's balanced.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so we
know what we're doing.
All right, this is starting
to get cluttered, right,
I'm not happy with this.
I'm not a neat freak,
my wife kind of is.
No, I shouldn't say anything
about my wife on this
because it's going
to be recorded.
No, she's not a neat freak,
she's a very wonderful woman.
OK, so, god I'm in
so much trouble.
All right, all right, so
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to make a new method
that will clean the place up.
We'll call it public static
void, we'll call it hqCode.
This is the headquarters
code and it's the stuff
that I want the
headquarters to do.
And I'm just going
to copy this in here
and then I'm going to
put hqCode there, bing.
So now, I'm calling this method
which I've defined below.
And that'll just insert
that code right in there,
really convenient.
Now, can anybody
tell me why there's
a red underline under spawn?
AUDIENCE: Game action exception.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, a
game action exception.
So what'll happen is I'll
just click on this button
and now this code
will have-- this guy
will throw the exception.
So, exceptions from
here will throw up
and they'll throw to here and
then they'll throw even more.
Now, let's say
that we don't want
to throw them all the
way up to the top.
Because you don't want run
to ever throw an exception
because it causes
your robot to explode.
So, how do you prevent thrown
things from getting out?
If Billy throws
me a football, how
do I keep the
football from hitting
my house, which is behind me?
AUDIENCE: Catch it.
PROFESSOR: That's
right, I catch it.
OK, and in Java,
the way that that's
done-- I know a lot of you
this already, but some of you
don't and you're going to
think that was a really
clever analogy-- is you
put try on the outside.
All right, and then you put,
I think I want to put it here,
I want to put catch here.
Yeah.
And so, specifically,
I want to make sure
that I catch the exception.
So, I'll go, I'll
catch exception
e, which will be whatever
exception comes out of try
will go into e.
Now, you see that the
tabbing is messed up
because try should
have a tab after it.
So I just highlight
this and I do control I
and that automatically
tabs it out.
95% of you knew that
already, but the 1%, the 5%--
I can add-- the 5% that
didn't know are like, oh,
that saved me so much
time, I'm so happy.
Yeah, so you we're going
to catch the exception
and then we're going to
do System.out.printline
and we're just going to
say "caught exception
before it killed us."
Yeah, and we're going
to just print it.
So we're going to go
e.printStack.Trace,
and we'll pick the third
one because it looks good.
Yeah, so now when
there's an error
it'll just print down to here,
rather than killing the robot.
At the same time, I should
mention, that any time a try
finds an error and moves to
catch you get 500 bytecode
penalty right there.
So, that's not a great
way to write code.
You want to avoid,
you want to avoid
having the exceptions at all.
All right, all right,
but we're getting
stuck because we haven't
had as much killing
as we really wanted to have.
So, I've got an idea for how to
make code that kills the enemy.
So, let's go with that idea that
I have, that I definitely have,
and I'm not coming
up with on the spot.
So that, let's--
that was a joke,
I actually am not coming
up with it on the spot.
I'm so offended that you
didn't find that it was joke.
I just have to find out
where it is in the notes.
It's in, it's in,
capture encampments,
oh, yeah, let's not
capture an encampment yet,
because that's not as exciting
as-- because what we'd really
like to do is just
defeat the enemy
and then we'll worry
about shaming them
into a greater
defeat, subsequently.
So, let's see here,
if you're a soldier,
maybe the right
thing to do is start
by massing up your
troops in a place.
So, let's get a place
to mass up the troops.
Now, maybe you only
want to do this once.
It's like a rally
point for everybody.
So, let's get this rally point.
I'm going to make it here
because I want everybody
to know where this
rally point is.
So, a rally point
is a map location
because you want everybody
to localize around a place.
Now, a map location
is yet another object,
like RobotController, and it has
its own methods and properties
associated with it that you
can find in the Java Docs
and that you can call-- and
that you can find your own way.
So, let's do this,
MapLocation rallyPoint.
Yeah, we're just going
to rally somewhere.
This is going to be a
good strategy, trust me
you're going to be excited.
So, let's do, let's find
the rally point, start out.
So, let's make a function
because it's already
getting far too fluffy, I think.
So, let's find the
rally point here.
We'll say rallyPoint
= findRallyPoint.
Yeah.
Now, where should we rally?
I think a decent place--
oh, look at this,
it's even going to
help me out here.
It noticed that
there's no method,
so I can just click here and
it'll make me a nice method.
Look at that, it's
just like this hqCode
with the private
static and then it
has the type that it returns.
See, this time we're making a
function that returns a type.
This didn't return anything,
it just did code here.
But now, we want it
to spit out an answer.
So, we're going to have it
return a map location when
it's done.
So, what we'll do is we're going
to get some location between us
and the enemy, seems
like a great place
to rally our troops.
So, between us and the enemy.
Let's see, the
enemy location-- so,
I'm just going to make this
nice and simple-- MapLocation
enemyLoc.
You can define variables
anyway, this'll
be local to this function.
The enemy location
is rc.senseEnemy.
Yeah, there.
OK, MapLocation, our location
is rc.senseHQLocation.
Yeah.
And now, I want to
find the average.
I'm not going to do it in
the smartest possible way,
I'm going to do it in a way
that's easy to understand.
Is I'm going to say
there's an integer
x which is enemyLoc.x
+ ourLoc.x.
All right, now, I guess if you
took the average of the two
that would be in between,
right, that would
be in between the two.
But we don't want it
completely in between the two
because we want to just
move a little bit out.
So let's make it more of ourLoc
and less of theirs, so three
of ours.
And now we put a
multiply and that
should get us one quarter
of the way to the enemy,
because it's mostly
us and somewhat them.
Yeah.
We'll do that for y as well.
There's probably smarter ways of
doing it than just writing out
two lines, but
it's pretty clear.
And now, what we'll
do is we'll use
the constructor
for map location.
So, we'll say mapLocation
rallyPoint = new MapLocation
and we give it an x and a y.
Yeah.
Yeah, all right, now we can
just say return rallyPoint.
OK, so now, we're going to
try to go to the rally point.
RallyPoint has been defined
here, that's useful.
So now, later we don't have
to give it a direction.
We can just say Direction dir
= getLocation.DirectionTo.
Now we'll go to the
rallyPoint instead.
Yes, yes, to the rallyPoint.
Let's see if our robots are
going to the rallyPoint.
I recommend that you try
running your code every time
you make a significant change.
And look, they did, they
went to the rallyPoint,
but they went there
in a dumb way.
Because when one of them
was in front of the other,
they couldn't go around.
Because now, this guy
can't spawn anymore robots.
I'm pretty sure he's trying,
but it's not working.
In fact, what error
am I getting here?
I'm getting you cannot move
in the direction non or Omni.
That's an interesting problem.
That's the problem that when
a robot is on top of the spot
he shouldn't try to move to
the spot that he's on top of.
So, we should also specify
that there's a distance
and he should only try
moving if there's a distance.
So, let's just put dist
= rc.getLocation.--
do you always do that too,
I always put i before o--
.distanceSquaredTo, and
distanceSquaredTo rallyPoint.
Yes, that's a useful method.
There are a lot of useful
methods for getLocation.
And you might say,
all right, how
was I supposed to know
that distanceSquaredTo
was a method from getLocation.
I was going to write my
own manual function that
goes looking for x's
and y's, and squaring
them, and subtracting them,
and so on, not that subtraction
is really even relevant here.
But, how was I supposed to know?
Well I'll tell you how
you were supposed to know.
You just go to where
you installed it.
I put it in Battlecode 2013.
You go to doc and you go to
this thing, all classes frame,
and this shows you
all the classes.
And one of those classes
here is Map Location.
And under Map Location, you see
that you can add map locations
to directions, you can add
them to x's and y's, you
can use directionTo,
distanceSquared,
you can check whether two map
locations are equal to one
another, if they're
adjacent to one another.
That's pretty useful.
So, having a working
understanding or memorization
of these things will
help you along the way.
So, now we've got
distanceSquaredTo.
So now, we only want to
move toward the enemy.
So, if our distance
is greater than 0,
then we'll try moving there.
Otherwise, let's not,
because it's just
going to end up
giving us trouble.
And once again I'm going to do
control i to do this indenting.
But this is getting
somewhat cluttered,
so why don't I just make
this soldierCode, especially
here when everything
is a giant font 16.
So, this is soldierCode
and I'll just
go ahead and have
it automatically
create me that method.
I'm going to go ahead and
put this in the method.
And now rc.move has got
a throw declaration.
Do you see this?
Pretty soon I'm not
even going to need
to be here because it's doing
everything for me, my goodness.
So now, they should
go to the rally point
and they shouldn't be throwing
quite as many exceptions
as they were before.
Oh, look at that, in
the game output window
you see no exceptions from
round 0 to 5,000, excellent.
But, again, they're just
stuck behind one another.
How can we make it so
that they're not stuck?
Well, here's a
good way to do It.
So, here you're only
trying one direction,
but now let's make a way
to try multiple directions.
The way that I'm about to show
has its own emergent complexity
built in.
You're going to like this
a lot, I believe, so.
Yes, let's do it.
Let's define a list.
Now, lists are defined this way,
you put an open square bracket
and I'm going to make
a list of integers.
Because I'm also going to
use some tricks for direction
because a lot of you are
probably thinking, oh gosh,
I noticed in the Java Docs
that direction-- oh here, I'm
going to go to Java Docs
again-- direction is here
and there's all
these directions,
east, north, northeast, blah.
There are eight directions.
I can rotate them
left and right,
but am I really going to
enjoy rotating them again
and again to find which
direction I'm going to.
OK, I could go forward,
if forward is blocked,
then rotate the direction
left, if the left is blocked,
then rotate-- no that
would be actually really
annoying to write.
And it's not the most
elegant way to do it.
The way we're going
to do is we're
going to get the
direction values
and then we're going to
use the direction list.
So, the direction list
consists of these eight things.
I believe it starts
at north and then
it goes around to northwest.
And so, direction
list at 0 is north.
And so, I'm going to show you
how we're going to do that
and what amazing result it
has, because a lot of you
already know how
to code, but you
don't know what amazing
result it's going to have,
or maybe you do.
So, this integer I'm going
to call the directionOffsets.
And you can define
an integer list
by setting it equal
to this construct.
So, I'm just going
to put curly brackets
and now I'm going to do
0, 1, -1, 2, -2, yes.
So, that now gets me
some direction offsets
and I need to start
checking directions.
So I'll use for integer d among
the list directionOffsets.
So now, this for loop
will loop again and again
and it'll put one of these
integers in each time it runs.
So, the first times
it runs, d will be 0,
the second time d
will be 1, and so on.
So this is for d
in directionOffsets
and there needs to be an s.
And what I'll check is if I
can move in that direction.
So, let's go ahead
and check that.
Oh, by the way, let's
simplify matters a little,
because we've got is
active here but there's
no reason to look at directions
if you're not active.
So, let's go ahead and put
this is active up here.
Oh gosh, the guys of you who
are following on your laptops
must be just frantic
at this point,
yes, because it's
like that, it's
very emotional, very personal.
So then, what we'll do is
we'll check if you can move.
If you can move-- Oh, but
wait this isn't right,
what direction is now important?
Direction
lookingatCurrently-- you
can name these whatever you
want-- the direction you're
currently looking
at is the following.
First, you want to
look at direction.
And so, see dir up here is the
direction to the rally point.
So, we'll look at
direction we'll say, OK,
what is, oh, let's
see here, ordinal?
Ordinal gives me
which number this
is in the list of
eight directions.
So, if I'm currently
looking at north,
that is to say if the direction
of the rally point is north,
then dir.ordinal will return 0.
Because the list of directions
starts with north and in Java
the index of a list starts at
0, so the first element is at 0.
So dir.ordinal gets me 0.
And then I'll add the
direction offset number
and now I will index
into directions again.
So, I'll say Direction.values
is a list of directions.
And the part of
that that I take,
indicated by the square
brackets, will be dir.ordinal
+ d.
I'll add 8 to make sure
that's it's not negative,
and then I'll do mod
8, the %8 is a mod 8.
And you're going to find,
this may be alien to you
to begin with, but you'll find
that this kind of construction
helps you out immensely.
So now, you're looking
at a direction currently.
If you can move in that
direction, what you want to do
is leave this loop.
You don't want to stay
in the loop anymore.
It's giving me this,
oh yes, semicolon?
No, that's not right.
Oh right, right, if I can move.
I forgot to put if I can.
Yeah, thank you for
catching that me, yes.
If I can move the direction
I'm currently looking at I
want to leave this loop, so
I'm throwing a lot at you,
but here you go.
We'll name this thing
the lookAround loop.
And now, we can do
break lookAround.
And now, that will get
us out of this piece.
Yeah.
Everybody likes
to be splashed in.
Nobody likes the first 27 pages
of that intro to C++ book that
talks about declaring variables
and what the hell private
static means.
It doesn't matter what
private static means,
you don't need to know,
you don't need to know.
Don't you think?
I hate that.
I tried to learn
languages so many times,
here I'm thumping the desk.
Anyway, I have
nothing but animosity
for their correct
ways of doing things.
That's why I don't study
number theory, my goodness.
AUDIENCE: Nonsense.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
because they prove
that addition works before
they do any addition.
I can't imagine how
they get anything
done under those circumstances.
So, you can see here that
nothing works at all.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Let's see, the robot
is spawned, but it never moves.
OK, so it can move, but it
never actually did move.
That's right, so what we
need to do is make it move.
So, within this loop, we've
just exited the lookAround loop,
that's this one.
So, we're just going to
put rc.move-- please move,
please move-- atCurrently.
Yes, when this guy
moves-- Did I-- Oh, scope.
Oh man, these guys are smart.
So, you see here that
this is inside this block
so it can't be
accessed from outside.
So, what I'll do is I'll define
it outside and I'll just equal,
I'll pre-initialize it at dir
and then when I use it in here
it'll be accessible
to that out there.
Look, you think
I made a mistake,
but it was actually
deliberate so that everybody
would know about this scope
problem, as you refer to it.
Although, to be honest, Scope
to me just means Listerine.
All right, so now, what they're
doing, it's hard to see,
but they're moving
around one another
and they're oscillating.
See that?
Look at yellow.
He's going around and
that's because he's
looking at the best
direction that he can go in.
Yeah, that's pretty cool.
What is going on here?
Cannot move in the given
direction west, south, blah,
blah, blah.
Now why can't they
move in that direction
is an interesting
question to ask.
And it may be
because some of them
are entirely surrounded
by other robots.
This guy, for
example, may end up
being entirely
surrounded by the robots.
One of the problems
that you will encounter
is that every round
robots move and they
don't move synchronously.
So it'll be really
instructive, if I
had the time I would
show you that the number
of adjacent robots is not the
number that you might expect.
Because, for example,
let's say this guy
wants to move to the right.
Let's just say he does.
He can't move to
the right this turn
if he executes before this guy.
Let's say they both want
to move to the right.
But if this guy
executes first then
he'll move to the right,
that'll take place,
and then when this guy
looks surround himself
he's going to see
an empty spot there.
It can be very
confusing for debugging.
So, that's going to happen.
And you might ask, OK, OK,
I recognize that nothing
can run synchronously because
then two robots can try
to move onto the same tile and
who knows what would happen.
It could be like Pauli
Exclusion Principle is violated,
two electrons occupy
the same orbital
and the world comes to an end,
a screeching halt, as it were.
So, here's how we do it.
We use the robot ID.
Now this is going to come back
later, so don't think that it's
just an obscure little
thing, this is important.
So, you can see here that
when I click on a robot
it tells me-- Oh, is
this bothering you?
I can tell it's
bothering half of you.
You've got like a
twitch developing,
you're starting to shake,
the sweats are coming out.
No sorry, that's me.
So, the robot, you
can see here, this
is robot 38, the headquarters.
This is robot 115, the lower
the robot number, the sooner it
executes, because they
execute in that order.
And I think when a robot dies
it's number becomes available
and another one can
spawn into that number,
in case you wanted to know.
That's all too nitty gritty.
So anyway, there we've got it.
Let's start owning
some noobs as it were.
Let's destroy the enemy.
It's not going to be as exciting
if we're all the same person.
So, let's make sure
that we know who we are.
Now, one problem here is that
this only goes to rallyPoint.
Let's put in an argument
to soldierCode and change
the name so it's
more reasonable.
So, that it's goToLocation.
That's kind of nice.
And we'll give it
MapLocation whereToGo.
Yeah, now we'll just
put this in here
and now this goToLocation
function can be reused.
So first, we'll just
goToLocation rallyPoint
and then after a certain
number of turns maybe
then we'll just go
to the enemy base.
Because we'll have all
these clumped up guys,
we'll be ready to
own some noobs.
So let's do that.
Let's go to the enemy
base, let's kill them dead.
So let's say here,
how are we going
to figure out what round it is?
This is sort of an obscure
function, Clock.getRoundNum.
I don't think that
there's really,
is there anything else under
clock that's worth looking at?
Clock, get bytecode
number, oh, you
can get the number of
bytecodes you have left,
that's pretty useful.
So you can say, oh, is it
worth doing this computation,
I don't know if I need that
many extra digits of pi.
So here, if my clock,
which returns an integer,
if that clock number
is less than 500,
yeah maybe, let's just make
it 200, we don't have all day.
Yeah, we'll make it 200.
If it's less than 200,
then go to the rallyPoint.
If it is more than
200, or equal to 200,
let's go to rc.senseEnemy--
Yeah, let's go to the enemy,
let's just go ahead
and kill them.
So now, we've got these
two pieces in here.
We're going to take our
Awesome Robot player.
We're going to play
against Hardbot.
Yeah, a bot that's supposed
to be hard on my map tiny.
Yeah.
Cannot move and get-- Well,
let's just hope that that's not
going to be a problem.
OK, so I'm getting
ready, getting ready,
get ready for the blitz.
It's round, it's round 150,
it's round 150, go, go, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Yes,
knocking them out.
Wa-bam.
One thing that's
important is you've
got give yourself a little pat
on the back from time to time.
That's what teammates are for,
to pat each other on the back.
My brother always
used to do that.
He'd give me a giant five
star, when you slap someone
so hard on the back that
it leaves a handprint.
Yeah, but that let me know that
he cared, that was important.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: I think
every younger brother
needs that and if you're the
oldest brother in your family
then just hit the
guy twice as hard.
So yeah, you see here
that that worked.
I might just go ahead and send
myself an email saying Max,
you sly dog, you made a player
that beats the hard bot.
I mean, the hard bot's
not actually very hard.
All right, all right,
so we've got that.
That was good, that was good,
but maybe what we'd rather do
is be more hunter like
about, we'll be stealthy.
What I think will
be really cool is
to go after the
closest enemy unit.
Now, you'll find in
the documentation
a lot of ways of
getting enemy data.
You can sense where their
encampments are and go
after those, you can sense
where your mines are,
you can sense where
its headquarters are,
the enemy robots are.
And you'll probably find
yourself, at some point,
going through a list and
trying to find the closest
enemy, or maybe the
closest allied unit.
So, we're going to do
an example of that.
And what we're going
to use it for is--
See, for example, this case
where they're trying to build
this encampment and they're
shooting at all of our dudes,
and our dudes are just,
they're getting hurt.
They should just go
gang up on that guy.
Why aren't they
ganging up on him?
So, let's make a function
for ganging up on the enemy.
And it'll require that we
locate the closest enemy.
I mean, we could
probably just go
to the first one
that's in the list.
So, I don't know which
one should we do?
In fact, how about
this, we could,
we could make code--
Yeah, let's try this.
OK, this is interesting.
I don't always plan, but when
I do I drink-- No, nevermind,
that doesn't work.
So, let's see if you
can copy a package
and then we'll be able
to play Awesome Robot
player against
Awesomer Robot player.
Yeah, paste.
OK, enter a new name.
Oh, that was helpful.
I mean, it's not very smart,
AwesomeRobotplayer.copy?
No, it's Awesomer.
Yeah.
Look at that, and it
even changed it for me.
I tell you, I'm going
to be out of a job
before the end of the week.
So, what we want to do now,
in the remaining moments
of lecture, is we want to
find the closest enemy robot.
Now, it may be that there
are no enemy robots.
This is the thing that I
was talking about before.
Let's do it, let's do it.
OK, try.
So here, I'm a soldier.
OK, I don't need to do
it if I'm a headquarters.
So, let's just do
it if I'm a soldier.
We'll say MapLocation
of the enemy robot
because, after all, all we
currently do is go to places,
we go there and
it's implied that we
kill all the things
that we find.
Yes, so the map location
of the closest enemy.
Now, let's see here.
This is only going to be
valid when there are enemies.
You've got to think about this.
So let's instead do, let's
get all the enemy robots.
So, this is a robot list,
a list of enemy robots,
we'll call it
enemyRobots, if we like.
Doesn't matter what we call it.
And we'll go rc.sense--
now this is the hardest
thing to remember, this is the
hardest ever possible thing
to remember--
senseNearbyGameObjects.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's hard to remember
because it's so accurate.
Robot.class, so we want
robots, we want them anywhere.
This is the range,
the squared range
that we're interested
in picking up enemies.
Now note, they won't
show up unless they
are within one of my
allied units' sight range.
I put in this huge
number just because I'm
willing to take those.
I put in a million and then
I'm going to make sure that
they're enemy by doing
rc.getTeam, so that's my team,
and .opponent is a team method
that gets me the opposing team.
Now the two teams are
Team A and Team B.
So, that's literally
written out as Team.A.
So I could have written
Team.A or Team.B,
but then I would have had to
check if I was Team A or Team
B. So, you're better
off doing it this way.
So, I'm sensing the
nearby game objects.
Now, I need to know if that
gave me any game objects.
So, I don't know how
big this list is.
If the list has a length, if
enemyRobots.length = 0, well,
then there are no enemy robots.
So, I should just do the same
thing I was doing before.
So, there you go.
Now, we've got code
that should be working.
But, if there are robots--
Now, what have I done here?
I haven't commented a
single line of code.
OK, enemies, no enemies nearby.
Yeah.
I heard somebody tell a
real zinger over there.
No, I'm just kidding.
So, no enemies--
OK, someone spotted.
OK, enemy is spotted.
So, yeah, no that's not right,
I put this in the wrong spot.
You guys are not
helping me, not helping
me nearly as much
as I was expecting.
So, now what I'll
do is I'll loop
through each of the robots.
Now, I could do the
same looping thing
that I did before,
where I could say,
Robot arobot among enemyRobots.
And then, it would put
arobot into each one,
but instead I'm going to
do it a different way just
to demonstrate it.
I'm going to define
an integer i = 0.
And then, there you go.
Oh, thank you, I saw you
we're going to help me
and I really appreciate it.
And we'll make sure
that i-- And so, this
is the format for a loop
that goes with this type.
Some of you are going
to be like that's
not the way that the words
work that make it explained.
And I'll tell you
that you are right
and you get a gold medal,
as soon as we mint them.
So yeah, enemyRobots.length
and we'll do i++.
So this'll make, i will
go up by one every turn.
So now, I can type Robot
arobot, it's an enemy robot,
= enemyRobots at i.
And now, I'm going to look
through and find the closest
one.
Now, I'm sure somebody's going
to show me a way that I'm
doing it wrong, but here's
how I'm going to do it.
I'm going to keep track
of which one was closest
and how close it was.
So int closestDist,
and I'm going
to initialize it
at a large number.
And I'm going to
make it a location.
And I'll do MapLocation
closestEnemy.
Yeah, closestEnemy.
OK, so now, we'll have--
Now this is very tricky.
This little bit of sequence is
very tricky in the Battlecode
API.
When I first did
Battlecode, they
didn't give an example of
this and it took me 10 years
to figure it out.
This is how to find
out where an enemy is.
You type rc, that's
like you're starting
from you, senseRobotInfo.
All right, and then
you pass it the robot.
You tell it to sense
the robot info.
Now what does that get you?
Does that get you the location?
No, that would be
too easy. , So,
that gets you a
robot info object.
So, now you've got
RobotInfo arobotInfo = that.
So now, I've got
some robot info.
Robot Info is yet another
one of these classes.
So here in the Java docs.
Look at this, I keep opening
more and more of them.
That's another one,
there's another one,
they're multiplying.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So here, you could
see Robot Info, there it was.
So, you can see that information
about the enemy robots
can be things like the
amount of shields they have,
the type of robot, its location.
One of the Robot
Info things is Robot.
So, what you can do is
you can sense the robot,
you can get the
robot, sense its info,
and then do info.Robot, and
then sense that things info,
and then you'll have the info.
So, you go back to
the robot and it'll
be a really nice little loop.
It's wonderful, it's just,
[KISSING SOUND] mmm, just
great.
I highly recommend
that kind of code.
It just warms my heart.
So, like what a little kid
does, is that computationally
impressive?
No, but it's cute, so
it warms it anyway.
So, that was the reasoning
behind that crazy stream
of logic.
So, here we go,
we got Robot Info.
Let's check the distance,
we'll be done with it.
So we'll say that the
distance, which is an integer,
equals
arobotInfo.location.distanceSquaredTo.
Of course, you can write your
own distanceSquaredTo metric
or something or other, but we're
just going to do it this way.
And we're going to make
it the distance from,
I guess, it could be
myself, as the robot.
So, distanceSquaredTo, hmm,
it's sort of hard to decide.
It could be the one
that's closest to me,
or let's just do
me for the moment.
Maybe later we'll make
it more complicated.
Actually, we're going
to run out of time
and we're just going to
end up eating Indian food.
But that's wonderful.
How many of you have
eaten at India Samraat?
That place is fantastic.
Wow, oh my goodness,
you're in for such a treat.
I don't know if it's
going to be considered
the same level of
treat as-- Oh anway,
I'm just going on and on.
So if the distance that we're
currently looking at is less
than the closestDist, then
we'll say that is the new
closestDist, and we will
assign closestEnemy=.
Well, I didn't
record it anywhere.
It's this one.
Yes, so there it is.
That's the closest enemy.
So, once again, if
there were no enemies
nearby we would either go to
the rallyPoint or goToLocation.
But now, what we want
to do-- Oh, goodness,
hey quit sending me
things on the-- Anyway.
So now, what we'll do is we'll
just go straight to the enemy.
That's what we'll do.
If we see one,
we'll go kill them.
So now, what we'll do
is we'll pit this code
against the previous
version of this code
and we'll see which one wins.
It's an interesting question.
Which code is better, to go
straight for the enemy base,
or to go for the
closest enemy robot?
Because maybe on
their way to the base,
I mean everybody shoots
on the way to everywhere,
but what's the best thing?
I'm think it'll be
quite interesting.
So let's see, where do we shoot?
It's here.
So, now we can go
to the location.
And we can go to
the closest enemy.
Yeah, because there's guaranteed
to be an enemy to go to.
Oh bother.
It's another one
of these things.
No, wait that's there,
goToLocation, closestEnemy.
Oh, right I've got
to initialize it.
Yes, so I put null.
It'll never see null, but I've
got to put it there anyway
so that it's comforted.
I believe that's the technical
explanation for what's
going on in the
background of Eclipse.
I'm pretty sure.
So now let's run.
Oh man, this is getting
exciting, it's 5:55.
I guess I'll have
some closing remarks.
But this'll be the
thing that is supposed
to be exciting and amazing.
We'll have awesome
versus awesomer.
All right, these guys are
so, they have a lot of fun.
That's so important.
I didn't say that again.
All right so, raise your hand
if you think that Awesome Robot
player, the original
awesome is going to win.
Three hands.
How many people think that
Awesomer Robot is going to win?
Four hands.
OK, well, I recognize
that premature arthritis
can be caused by coding.
Raising an arm may
be beyond some of us,
in terms of, oh, ohh.
OK, we're going to find out.
OK, I actually don't
know the answer.
OK, so they're just grouping.
It's round 70, round
80, it's round 100.
At round 200, exciting
stuff's going to happen.
I wish we could slow this down.
It's going to
happen all at once.
Boom.
Ah.
Oh, but they stopped them.
They stopped them.
The Awesomer player
has won, hurray.
Did you see that?
It was all too fast.
It just went by before, I mean
before I even noticed it was,
ah goodness gracious.
So, here it goes.
These guys will run
back to the base,
but these guys will be following
them the whole way through.
OK, so let's back
it up a little bit.
This is interesting.
Now, I think if you
push like f, or b, or c,
you can turn off the
circles, maybe not.
OK, so they're
forming a concave.
Oh man, a lot of
them are blowing up.
It's hard to tell
what's going on.
OK, so here it looks pretty
darn even, 1,2,3, 4,5,6,
7,8,9 versus 1, I can't
tell if he's dying,
2,3,4, 5,6,7, 8,9,10.
OK, so it's 10 versus 9.
The blue guys have done
well, pretty well already.
Oh, but then they
just ping, they just
ping and turn around
and kill everything.
I've got to step
forward more slowly.
This is a fast-paced
game, let me tell you.
Let me tell you,
you're not going
to be here for an hour
watching somebody--
Oh man.
OK, so these guys are
all working over there.
Oh, look at that.
Meanwhile, these
guys are ganging up
on him and these three guys are
getting totally double-teamed,
or quadruple-teamed, or whatever
the word is, by these fellows.
Oh, I'm pointing with my
finger, how can you see that?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Oh, my goodness.
Look I'm enjoying myself OK.
Yeah, and then they turn
around and they kill the enemy,
and then they turn around
and they kill the enemy base.
There you have it, boom, done.
All right so, final
closing remarks.
I'm looking at the wrong page.
Yeah, so improvements
to this robot,
there's lots of things that you
could do, that you would do,
that are worth doing.
For example, everybody's
making decisions independently,
you could be using messaging.
I think this is a big point
because somebody asked me
the other day, what is
the point of messaging.
Because all of my
robots have access
to all of my other robots' data.
And you saw that happen here.
Because would these
guys have been
able to respond intelligently?
Would this guy have come--
Gosh, I'm using my finger
again-- would these fellows be
able to come all the way back?
I agree Steven, I should
close GChat when presenting.
Would these guys have been
able to come all the way back
to here if they didn't
have shared data?
No, they wouldn't.
So, they have shared data, why
would you ever use messaging?
Because you could simplify it
by having your headquarters do
the processing,
and say, all right,
I want everybody
to attack this guy.
And then they all just go
ahead and follow that command,
rather than having to do
the processing themselves.
Because if everybody
has the same data,
why should everybody
process on the same data?
So, there you go
that is a reason,
it doesn't prove that
it's always better,
because it may be much better to
have a decentralized approach,
and so on.
There are very many
reasons, but there you go,
that's an answer
to that question.
You saw Awesome,
you saw Awesomer,
and you saw it right here.
Thank you for coming.
The next-- Just remain
calm in your seats
and there will be food.
The food guy probably
arrive already, I'm sorry,
yesterday I thought the
food guy hadn't arrived.
They don't mind being
called food guys,
don't worry it's not insulting.
I thought he hadn't
arrived, but I
think he was poking is head in
and out like a drinking bird,
and I just didn't see it because
of various myopia and such, no,
what do they call
it, tunnel vision.
So, yes, the next lecture.
I'm sure you enjoyed
this one a lot,
even if you know Java already.
Because you could see
the warmth and the smiles
on the faces of the people
who didn't know Java and now
do because of this
amazing whirlwind tour.
So, yes, the next lecture
will be on navigation,
as if this one wasn't.
Yeah, and you're going to hear
all kinds of amazing things
that you never
would've expected.
And you're going to see this
like awesome visualizer that's
a little bit like the fractals
that I was showing before.
It's made in Mathematica
and it's made in the USA.
And yeah, hurray.
So, thank you for coming.
And this is the end of lecture.
And I'll just be here
answering questions.
Again, there's
lab after lecture.
My god, this is like one of
those symphonies that you think
keeps ending, but
it doesn't end.
And that will be all.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]